rockstar games made a whole bunch of our
little game of hearts skip a beat
earlier today when they tweeted out this
image that strongly suggests something
red dead redemption this way comes rock
stars Twitter Facebook and official
website all now prominently feature the
logo which you might recall from red
dead redemption promotional artwork and
loading screens it's still unclear
exactly what the big red logo means as
the t's could be for a rerelease of red
dead redemption or for the highly
anticipated follow-up in april of 2016
we saw what appeared to be a map for a
red dead redemption to which had leaked
online and a source allegedly close to
the development confirmed it was indeed
a recent art direction map the original
red dead redemption came out for ps3 and
360 in May of 2010 just last week the
first game in the series red dead
revolver was re-released on ps4 so
nothing concrete for Red Dead fans to
pan in their calendars just yet but I
think it's safe to say a lot of us are
more than happy to be seeing red today
be sure to stay tuned to gamespot for
new developments
you